at Silicon Valley Bank we deal in
innovation
this means we have the coolest clients
of any Bank any pitched as a bank for
the businesses of the future customers
of Silicon Valley Bank are this weekend
locked out of their accounts with no
idea when or if they'll get access to
their funds
like lingumi an online tutoring tool run
from London use the bank's UK subsidiary
with 85 percent of the firm's cash tied
up there critical bills are coming up
tomorrow morning and I cannot walk into
a Sainsbury's right now and buy a banana
with our company money we do not have
access to it and that is true of 40 to
50 of Technology businesses technology
startups in the UK it is absolutely
critical that we get a solution as soon
as possible and tonight that solution
for the UK offshoot based here in
central London could be closing in the
Bank of London has confirmed it
submitted a formal offer to buy it Sky
News understands Oak North Bank founded
by an ex-tory donor is in talks as well
with interest also from HSBC JP Morgan
and the Middle Eastern fund but even if
a buyer is found the chancellor may
still need to step in to help firms with
immediate cash flow issues there is a
serious risk to our technology and Life
Sciences sectors and we are working get
Pace on a solution we will bring forward
very soon plans to make sure people are
able to meet their cash flow
requirements pay their staff
the chancellor is playing down risks to
The Wider economy but Tech bosses say as
well as damage to their sector there's
also the potential for a ripple effect
that does impact other walks of life
it's an unwelcome development days
before the budget especially for a prime
minister that's put technology at the
heart of his plan to grow the economy
never shy of hiding his California
credentials Rishi sunak went to
University 12 miles away from Silicon
Valley Bank's U.S base and frequently
talks of the importance of a thriving
Tech sector
and that's why this former Chancellor
says the solution needs to be found it
is going to affect the very important
fintech sector in our economy where
there's a huge concentration around
Silicon Valley Bank UK and there's a lot
of small early stage businesses that are
quite important to this economy
there's no talk of a bay light for
Silicon Valley Bank but there's still a
question for the government about how
much it's prepared to intervene the UK
offshoot says it will enter insolvency
if a buyer isn't found companies in The
Wider Tech sector face a nervous weight
robhouse guy news in East London